la première chose qui m'amuserait
c'est qu'on parle de Michel Sardou qui
est un véritable enfant de la balle mais
un vrai celui-là avec Madame
[Rires]
c'est on l'aime on l'aime pas mais il a
des grandes qualités de se faire aimer
je crois en tous les cas il est là il
est là une présence quoi
bien placé j'ai l'impression qu'il y a
une longue lignée derrière lui
du côté de mon père comme du côté de ma
mère
un comique de l'époque 1910 1920 25
c'est le genre
de ténor formidable une présence aussi
je crois que c'est de ça que ça du bien
il y a eu sa mère ma femme puis ma mère
moi aussi ça redonnette qui chantait je
suis la petite Sardou
la saison d'été en fait il était très
bien
ma grand-mère était faisait partie à
l'époque des petites femmes de Paris
c'était la mode à l'époque des petites
danseuses maintenant les danseuses sont
très grandes mais à l'époque c'était les
toutes petites qui t'habilles avec des
chapeaux claques avec des queues de pis
avec barrésistes c'est très joli et elle
fait elle avait formé un balai qui
s'appelait des petites femmes de Paris
elle était connue sous le nom de
Bagatelle et en plus elle avait fait
quelque chose d'assez remarquable ça a
été la première
femme à se montrer complètement à poil
sur une scène c'est-à-dire le nu
intégrale avant la lettre c'est à dire
que ma grand-mère était
enfin je disais on me l'a raconté
c'était par là à l'époque était très
belle c'était une petite danseuse et
dans une revue au Casino de Paris elle a
fait Cupidon alors Cupidon descendait
des cintres complètement à poil
naturellement avec une carte quoi et un
arc qui a fait au début hurler les gens
parce qu'à l'époque c'était pas du tout
on en était à peine à montrer ses
chevilles depuis on a fait du chemin
d'ailleurs c'était une précurseur dans
dans un genre
de la grand-mère habillée est-ce que
vous avez vu des photos oui j'ai vu des
photos de la grand-mère je l'ai connu la
grandeur après il m'a fait après elle
était devenue ma mémé
70 ans là c'est encore le cadré quand
même elle fait encore capable de faire
un cancan et très très bien mais il
reste à la fin à la fin de sa vie la
pauvette elle est des fois elle nous
servir et d'expliquer alors c'est énervé
d'expliquer comment qu'elle était au
casino et en servant les spaghetti ou
les ravioles il faisait deux petits
pains ou un grand écart au milieu de la
cuisine enfin ça c'était c'était très
fréquent c'est
une famille de fade mais en fait c'était
rigolo après il y a eu ma mère qui a été
danseuse aussi c'est drôle parce que ma
mère est née dans les coulisses du
Concert Mayol où ma grand-mère donc
dansait elle est née sur une panière
dans les coulisses du concert maillot ce
qui est déjà à la marqué à vie pour ça
dans sa vie future elle a été de
chanteuse danseuse elle a fait des
revues puis après elle a fait de la
comédie en fait on fait toujours
aujourd'hui
elle a rencontré mon père
du monde et moi comme elle était
pétardie avec elle parlait toujours et
qu'elle écrit voilà je voudrais pas une
môme comme ça moi et puis voyez ça c'est
fait un jour comme ça
il était à dire que c'est une étincelle
il y a le midi la Provence et Paris la
s'accroche ça fait des ça fait Michel oh
là là
alors du côté de mon père pardon c'est
beaucoup plus impressionnant parce que
ça remonte alors à la dégénération
croisade parce que oui
lui il parlait pas il jouait le samedi
dimanche la fantomime dans un amateur
bien sûr à Toulon est-ce que c'était
l'époque du Boulevard du Crime je crois
oui
mon grand-père était une très très
grosse vedette tout pour tout ce qui
touche à l'Afrique du Nord et le midi ça
plaît Valentin Valentin Sardou et il
faisait c'était un
il avait une voix de ténor il avait une
très très jolie voix elle avait fait de
l'Opéra et il était devenu comique
troupier avec sa voix enfin une sorte de
comique troupier parce que c'était pas
exactement encore le
véritablement le comique il a fait
d'ailleurs il avait comme partenaire à
l'époque un tout jeune homme qui
s'appelait Ouvrard
qui est pas droit j'ai le droit qui se
rentre chez le pilote qui se colore chez
les gosier et anémie et l'estomac bien
trop bas et les côtes bien trop haute
j'ai les hanches qui se démangent les
pigastre qui s'encastrent l'abdomen qui
se démène Gilles thorax qui se désaxe la
poitrine qui se débile les épaules qui
se frôlent je les rends bien trop fin
les boyaux bien trop gros j'espère un
homme qui se dégomme et le sacrum c'est
tout comme j'ai le nombril tout Embry et
le coccyx qui se dévisse ah bon dieu que
c'est en mettant d'être toujours
patraque avant d'excédent je ne suis pas
bien portant
[Applaudissements]
et ma mère jouait le Vénus
sortant de sa coquille pas toute nue non
parce qu'à ce moment-là le Maillol au
Maillol de nuit n'était pas encore
autorisé elle avait un maillot dit
académique vous savez qui m'ont laissé
le charme avantageux
et l'appareil c'est dans une mais la
Vénus était un petit peu enceinte en ce
moment-là alors évidemment le maillot le
maillot s'arrondissait et Mayol voulait
la faire remplacer alors elle pleurait
mais elle voulait pas surtout de voulait
pas quitter mon père qui était aussi un
Cavalaire terrible de l'époque alors
elle a attendu le dernier moment parce
que mon père voulait pas que jeunesse
dans les brumes du nord à Paris
maintenant il fallait naître dans le
Midi parmi le tente de maisons de cassis
et alors ma mère attendait pas enceintes
de la petite dans le temps de descendre
le midi c'est sans doute nerveux enfin
bref elle a entendu le dernier moment et
il est parti pour tenant à la dernière
minute et le 18 septembre 1910
un pardon s'est arrêté à la gare
d'Avignon et moi j'ai frappé à la porte
de sortie il y a rien eu à faire je suis
né dans la salle des pas perdus dans la
gare et ça a commencé encore faire une
blague d'ailleurs ma grand-mère de
Toulon quand j'étais pas sage je disais
celui-là il est pas de chez nous il est
du Nord
[Rires]
c'est mon père après leur don qui a
débuté aussi très tôt
il a fait d'abord
il a chanté à l'Alcazar de Marseille oui
et puis alors votre père a été
asservi a été servi par l'apparition du
cinéma
il avait puis en plus l'amitié qui est
le lit avec Rémi à l'époque il était il
était un petit peu le
qui protéger les entrées mieux à
l'époque quand il habitait c'est lui qui
avait créé notamment Marius au théâtre
parce qu'avant avant que ce soit un film
avant qu'elle soit le film ça a été
c'était une pièce dont personne ne
voulait parce que bien entendu comme
tout ce qui est génial et magnifique
Pagnol a gardé sa pièce dans les tiroirs
je ne sais combien d'années enfin tout
le monde lui disait ta connerie
marseillesea personne il n'est pas nulle
c'est
un charmeur c'est un talentueux
personnage
il vous charme il vous invite chaque
fois qu'on a fini une scène et oui
Hollywood ça y est tu pars à Hollywood
il ne faut pas l'écouter parce que c'est
pas vrai on ira jamais à Hollywood
[Musique]